years ago in the height of summer my
father told my brother and me a story he
only told it once and he refused to
speak of it ever again
when he was a young man in the year of
the false spring a great Southern Lord
held the largest Tony Westeros had ever
seen in the largest castle Westeros had
ever seen Knights and Lords from across
the Seven Kingdoms made their way drawn
by the spectacle and the size of the
champions purse even the king was
rumoured to be attending no none had
seen him in years
ours is a small house and my father had
come only to be part of the magnificence
whose like he'd never see again one
afternoon he was walking across the
field enjoying the warm spring day when
he was set upon by three Squires none
were older than fifteen yet all were
bigger than him this was their world as
they saw it and he had no right to be
there they snatched away his fear and
locked him to the ground cursing him for
a frog eater every time he tried to rise
they shoved him down and kicked him when
he curled up on the ground but then they
heard a shout that's my father's man
you're picking how old the she-wolf
Lyanna stark the young daughter of Lord
Rickard stark warden of the north and my
father's liege lord Liana laid into the
Squires with attorney sword scattering
me my father was bruised and bloodied so
she took him back to her tent to clean
his cuts and bind them up with linen
there he met her brother's wild Brandon
who led them the quiet Eddard
and benjin he was the youngest of the
four that evening there was to be a
feast in Haran ah
to mark the opening of the tourney and
Lyanna insisted that my father attend as
he was of high birth with as much a
right to a place on the bench as any
other man she was not easy to refuse
this wolf made so my father borrowed
suitable clothes from benjin and went up
to the great castle under herons great
roof my father ate and drank with his
fellow Northman a black brother besieged
the knights to join the Nights Watch the
Snickers and smiles Prince Rhaegar sang
a song so sad that it brought tears to
Leanna's eyes but when benjin teased her
for it she poured wine over his head
Lord Baratheon dragged down a night of
skulls and kisses in a wine cup war
my father remembered a beautiful woman
with purple eyes who danced with sir
Barristan Selmy and several others as
the end of the evening approached
Brandon stark asked her for one more
dance on his shy brother's behalf and so
Eddard Stark shared the last dance of
the celebration with Lady ashara dayne
abruptly the Hall went quiet
the Mad King had come after all and was
now entering the hall with his
Kingsguard he hadn't left the red key in
years and none could believe the state
of him his long yellow fingernails
tangled beard and ropes of unwashed
matted hair made his madness plain to
all nor was his behavior that of a sane
man for in the blink of an eye he could
go from hysterical laughter - weeping to
rage but when he commanded Sir Jaime
Lannister to kneel before him and swear
the oath of the Kingsguard before half
the Lords of the realm a cheer burst
from the crowd for sir Jaime was much
admired for his courage gallantry and
skill with a sort amidst all this
merriment my father spied the three
Squires who detect him attending their
Knights Liana saw them - and pointed
them out to her brothers I could find
you a horse and some armor that might
fit benjin offered my father thanked him
but gave no answer our people said a
boat more often than a horse and our
hands are made for oars not Lance's much
as he wished to have his vengeance he
feared he would only make a fool of
himself and shame his people Eddard had
offered my father a place in his tent at
night but before my father slept he
knelt on the lake shore looking across
the water to the Isle of faces and said
a prayer to the old gods the next day in
the tourney the three knights who
Squires had beaten my father unseated
their opponents and earned a place among
the champions but late in the afternoon
as the shadows grew long a mystery
Knight appear
lists he was short and clad an
ill-fitting armor cobbled together from
different suits on his shield was
painted a heart tree of the old gods a
white weirwood with a laughing red face
the mystery night dipped his Lance
before the king and rode to the end of
the lists whether five champions had
their pavilions you can guess the three
he challenged whoever the mystery knight
was the old gods gave strength to his
arm
all three Knights fell before him none
were well loved so the common folk
cheered the knight of the Laughing tree
as the new champion was soon called well
his fallen foes sought to ransom their
horses and armor the knight of the
Laughing trees voice boomed through his
helm and told them teach your Squires
honor that shall be ransom enough once
the defeated Knights chastise their
Squires sharply their horses and armor
were returned and so my father's prayer
was answered the king was furious in his
madness he suspected a traitor in his
midst perhaps even a newly made Sir
Jaime Lannister whom he had already sent
back to the red keep that night the King
asked Lord Robert Baratheon to take to
the lists and unmask the mystery Knight
declaring him no friend of his for the
next morning when the heralds blew their
trumpets and the king took his seat the
knight of the Laughing tree had vanished
all they ever found was his painted
shield hanging abandoned in a tree
my father's tale ended here he never
spoke more of R&R though he must have
seen Prince Rhaegar victory some whisper
that Prince Rhaegar himself had arranged
the entire tourney in secret as a way to
gather the great lords and address his
father's apparent madness perhaps even
remove him from the Iron Throne but when
I asked my father about this
he only shrugged sadly what Rhaegar
intended unconcerned all know what he
did